hello everyone welcome to episode 2 of
idiots and abroad i'm alana that that's
john that's jacob and that is rahul
screen because your bottom corner
you're all switched around from all your
travels alana i think you'll find that
from my perspective i was correct uh and
that's a lesson oh that's all that
matters then out in life is perspectives
are important this is what happens when
you go are you raising my perspective
are you just talking over my perspective
yes as a white woman
i feel like i'm entitled to do this
there's a white australian yes give
yourself some credit uh john
have you seen um did you watch
hard-boiled or the killer growing up did
you watch the the charion fat john woo
movies
no
oh those i've been meaning to get to
those because for about 23 years
he drinks his he's detective he's
tequila is his last name
charlie oh johnny tequila
yeah john do you want to tell people is
it johnny tequila
yeah i think so uh i invented a drink
called red sun rises
that is a reference to airborne
it is a tequila sunrise except with
blood orange it does look good um it is
good except i spilled a bunch of salt in
it because i tried to salt the rim and
then i put too much salt on it so i
rubbed it off but a bunch of it fell
into the drink
it wasn't so it's more like a salty dog
like a sip of the ocean yeah you showed
it before we started recording and it
was like
a little crystal ring that was around
the top what's everyone was drinking
oh right now i'm actually drinking coke
oh my goodness uh what but i do have
beverage backup i just have a coca-cola
a mexican coke which related i went to
mexico for the first time so that's cool
we'll get to nice
mexican cokes i'm drinking viking blonde
it's mead
they spelled blood wrong i know it's
really stupid i'm drinking it out of
this
horn appropriately
is that a real horse
shaped ceramic oh no yeah it's an actual
horn
oh my god
look it's got it oh there it is
oh wow
cool
what
raffle how about you what do you got
espresso
basically yeah and i'm in an espresso
mug i'm trying to i
will try and mention espresso as much as
i can even though apparently nestle are
a bad company i want to be the next uh
george clooney are you going for that
sponsorship i'll allow it a lot
everyone's allowed one i drop do you own
a 900 espresso machine rahul
it's not 900
i i'll tell you what i am now the proud
owner of
700
airbrush
oh yeah it's how you pose it yep oh man
it was a late night purchase for no
reason because i'm building rx-78
and you were texting me about it at like
1am yeah i was texting jacob
and
i basically said to jacob do you want my
because i i've just decided i want to
upgrade everything
um there you go and get the pro models
of everything so i asked jacob would he
like the compressor and stuff
that i currently have
so he can start painting and i'll teach
him how to paint
um i'm gonna get a whole class and then
i'll and i'll upgrade my my stuff
yeah go ahead
from
how much time
was there from
the thought of maybe i should upgrade my
stuff
to
buying the 700
airbrush
that's okay so there's two parts to that
no that's just give me 10 minutes
well no so what happened was the thought
i want to go and do this was quick it
was almost instantaneous
the research is what took it a bit
longer because i was like
what where's my step up to and i don't
want to make the same mistake before
which is i impulse buy
and then
once it's
shipping i start like getting excited so
i google it and realize that it's got
three stars this person said it's [ __ ]
um it was made by a company that funds
trump
all sorts happened later so i did the
research
you want to hear a sad sad story tell us
your sad tale i guess
i bought an rtx 2080
quite literally a week before uh the
3080 was announced did you not know
about that conference
listen i'm not a [ __ ] nerd i just
gained i'm a gamer very easy to track
jeffy i feel like a 20 gamer yeah that's
like buying although a ps4
day before five came out
you couldn't get either of them
right so like john you wouldn't have
been able to get a 3080 or a ps5 so that
seems all right yeah hey you got
something good nonetheless in any case
this is a travel show where we talk
about travel and we have lots of
adventures to talk about uh jacob and i
went to vegas yeah it was jacob's first
time since he was 14 i went to nicaragua
and to mexico
and john this is how i'm supposed to
start every episode of this show
we're about to write it in
it's a preamble it's fine where in the
world is john smith
damn
he's an assistant it's amsterdam that's
their thing
they call they call it the damn there no
just dance just do it we go every time
we go damn
that's cool have you heard the accent
much out there
yes
was that it right there our first little
lips oh crazy weather we're having today
in the dab in dam
i'm certain that's not how they sound
yeah i'll also allow that what is that
we do not accept visa
it's
they they slur it's like a sean connery
almost isn't it
a whole country i don't know i i have
auditory comprehension disorder
also i'm i'm very hot because
there's that's the one downside about
this place for all you audio listeners
it looks like i have a professional
streamer set up it's very cool but
that's because i lucked out with my
airbnb my last two airbnb the airbnb's
in korea were [ __ ] lemons compared to
this place this place badass
oh
like the only downside though is better
than korea
yep no
very much so wow for a white person
for an english speaker
for a
s
uh
monolingual colonizer
yeah there's the word we're looking for
monolingual colonizer yeah he has that
on refreshment i'm in amsterdam [ __ ]
yeah well why don't you um before we
jump into amsterdam tell us about the
tail end of your adventures in korea do
you have anything else to share
yes once you wipe the sweat from your
brow don't worry it'll be back soon
two things one shortly after
we recorded that podcast
um i'm not sure i don't remember if i
talked about my routine which was
uh i'd record i'd stream from like 10 to
two in the morning
and then i'd get a little bit of work
done and i'd be like i gotta go out see
see the city see the country
uh
and then i'd go out but i'd be so
anxious about
the awkward interaction that was going
to come when i tried to let go into a
restaurant or try to buy anything
uh
because of the language barrier
um that was
uh ubiquitous
i would say nearly ubiquitous
um that i would literally
walk around and be like i need to get
dinner i'm hungry and i'd walk around
for like an hour
like looking in a place analyzing it
from the outside because there are a
number of factors one
a lot of places are just designed for
groups and they won't even sit you if
you're one person yeah
food is a big part of culture in korea
but
communal food is what i learned is like
that's also a big thing interesting
and like yeah just a whole myriad of
things uh preventing me from just
walking into a place
uh and so
on a
thursday or friday night i was walking
around
and i was so hungry i had been walking
around for like 40 minutes looking at
different places i was like no there's
only groups of people sitting there
and then i walked by
these two
chubby
westerners
and i kept walking and i was like
hold on a second
i should interact i should just go hit
these guys up stick to your own
no get a group so you can eat you're
just looking for white people
well
listen if i i was looking for someone
who could speak who i knew that i could
comfortably go hey what are you guys
doing you guys want to hang out
because that's what i find i have
trouble i did try it and they're so
quiet they sit listen i tried that
multiple times listen i'm not going to
judge john you're using folks for a
snack it was it was nick
was the response i got oh yeah um
and uh so i went up to them turned out
they're from new zealand and they like
ran an amusement park here that are in
korea that was owned by a new zealand
company cool
still locals then yeah but i went up and
it was uh it was like an expat pub
and it was one of the first places i
found that served cocktails
um you couldn't which i guess if i
if i searched expat pub all of the bars
there i went to a few afterwards and
they all had just like a normal western
bar
uh but before that i was searching
cocktail bar and i was going to like
swanky cocktail bars
few and far between anyways
i went in there on an empty stomach
and after an awkward beginning because
we didn't have anything to talk about
and there were those you know those
lulls where you're talking to someone
and it's like everyone's just kind of
because
what are we gonna talk about next and
you've run out of amusement park roller
coaster questions yeah
yeah um
they started buying jaeger shots oh uh
jager bombs
um
and once again empty stomach hadn't
eaten since like noon it was about 8 p.m
this place didn't have food
i used i always forgot about that they
did have food but then once i finally
realized that i asked and they said
kitchen's closed oh god okay yeah cool
seven jager bombs and like oh no five
beers oh christ oh john
you vomited on an empty stomach you
vomited
no
what yeah tell us of your bodily
functions that came not involuntarily
it's the first time in my life and
hopefully the last time that i literally
was like
i was sitting there going
i can either get out i can't even sprint
out of here but these are like the first
people i've met where i'm actually
hanging out in them so i went to the
bathroom
and it's the first time i've ever done
this never gonna do it again i shoved my
fingers down my throat
and i threw up because this is already
when i'd learned the kitchen was closed
i get it i don't feel like that's that
bad you threw up a bunch of alcohol i
assume yeah and then i went back out and
i had like four more jager oh my gosh
i've never i've never made myself throw
up by pushing fingers in the back of my
throat but i have done it by spinning
around really fast
wait
you were like i need to throw i'm too
drunk i need to throw up and so you just
started spinning i think because i was
too drunk i didn't think about touching
like the back of my throat or something
a lot i think this is when we got pizza
in austin that one time oh yeah
in the bathroom
the bathroom and i was like i'm on the
i'm close enough to throwing up
but i'm not quite there yet let's get
there so i just like spun around a few
times really fast
oh my god i just imagine you spinning
around and going and just throwing up
all over the mirror
like a sprinkler i just hope there's
nobody in the bathroom saw my feet just
like going in a little circle you were
gone for a really long time and i just
always we all thought you were pooping
but i always remember that as how
happily you jogged off to the bathroom
you were like i just gotta go to the
bathroom
and you just sort of jolly skipped away
yeah and then turns out you were
vomiting he was putting on a face is
what he was doing he did a great job i
just really wanted to eat that pizza and
i don't think i was going to be able to
eat any of the pizza i thought i was
going to throw up so it was a good pizza
i love that i had a great night after
that
a good time bones disappeared anyway yo
that's how he does it the bone's always
disappeared
john so did you end up making permanent
friends with them did they alleviate
your food problems oh no here's what
happened and this is uh
it's a little weird
okay okay it's weirder than it already
is i was i was so drunk um that i even i
took pictures with everybody and then
posted on instagram and didn't know i
had done that until like four days later
when i opened instagram again
i saw i think i saw some of those uh
i was so dr and it was closing because
everything closed at 10 and i was like
oh god i gotta get out of here
and there was this there was this group
of girls
that one of them was sober or sober
enough one of them was like
angry drunk and then one of them was
like falling over
and one of the guys i was was like
check out her mate she's she's good to
go and i was like she looks too drunk
and he's like no she's she's good to go
and i was like
and i was so drunk that in my head i was
like
wait
is this stranger that i met leading me
astray or should i listen to him
and i was like
no
no
but then so then i became
i got to work with the sober friend to
get
her drunk friends in the car
um and that took like 20 minutes and
then what ended up happening was that
they one of them wouldn't leave without
me so then i got in the car because i
was so drunk so then we were driving
away and i was like all right we did it
and the surfer was like why are you in
the car i was like
i don't know
and so uh
i got out
and then the drunk one of the drunk ones
was like no i want to go with you and
started running so i was like look your
friend has something to say and she
turned around and then i sprinted away
my god
oh my god i literally so the night
started with me going maybe i should hit
up those people and then it ended with
me
literally sprinting away blackout well
brownout trunk i guess because i
remember that
well so you made it home that's what
happens when you interact with
are these pictures still up can i find
them yeah it's still up there are they
john just wanted some lunch yeah you
were just trying to get food so did you
solve any of your eating problems after
that point like did you continue to go
to western bars
well it was everything was closed
everything closed at 10.
there it is yeah there they all are you
can check it on my instagram
um
i think i ordered food or something i'm
not sure
i don't hey where was um where was doug
in all of this
but i did meet up with doug we met up uh
we both took the train to this other
place i think called young gyeongju
maybe
um
and this was after the podcast came out
and he was very excited uh to be
mentioned
very excited wow but he did have some
beef with you rahul
because he was saying that you had
mistranslated
yeah uh
or that he had mistranslated the fishy
the fishy ocean stuff
yeah
yeah but he
vehemently is that how you say it yes
denied that
uh and then the rest of the day
uh
i would like go what does that say and
you go oh that means temple and you can
tell rahul
that i it's that is what it is
okay
calm down duh wow
yeah rahul doug's got beef you better go
to korea i've got korea with you guys
you'll get slapped i know we might have
to see doug in the comments see is he
tasty we'll hear from him what's his
bill what's his build type is he tasty
before i say anything
pretty tasty kind of looks like a like a
svelte librarian
he's felt
i don't know what that word means but
yeah sure
i think it smells i mean fancy
i thought it was i thought it was like
salt is what i meant to say gestalt oh
i'm sorry doug
yeah that's changed how i felt if you
were like you know how tall is he
uh
six nine
oh sorry that i called him out on the
previous podcast
yeah i apologize yeah spelt means uh
slender and elegant svelte is fancy no
he's not spelled he is not
spelt
sorry
doug one other one other thing that
happened before i left korea just
anecdotal uh has actually met up with
some korean streamers
this married couple that go on to handle
exbc but i think they're like og twitch
or i mean not og twitch but they've been
streaming for a long time they have like
a big uh user base they're it was you
know back in the wild west they got that
backpack they just started streaming all
they do is they roll around busan
um and they stream in england they speak
in english
and the wife hussu
didn't speak english at all when they
started doing twitch so through six
years of streaming on twitch
to english viewers she's now
fluent but is it only like twitch things
like pogba's and stuff she doesn't yeah
that's she she says pogba is way too
much
to subscribe
how'd you uh how did you find them how
did you ended up one of my viewers
mentioned it really okay xbc's live
right now you should go hang out with
them they're in busan i was like excuse
me wait so did you kind of like dox them
a little while you showed up at that
location
no i didn't i didn't just like be like
oh yeah i'll go meet up with them and
then show up like
hey guys i'm on twitch too
um i dm'd and then we did dinner the
first night and then
uh we did this thing that's really cool
they call it hide and seek but then
during the throughout the day we changed
it to
geo guess or irl or irl geo gesture
because basically
the dude esko
went off
and
was taking pictures
of like where he was and then we had to
use detective skills
to figure out
where he was
and then he led us along this trail
um
sleuths you were international yeah yeah
and
it was really cool and i told him uh
that i wanted to see kind of like the
seedier side of busan so he took me
through all these back streets
it was basically four hours of stairs
though because there are these uh
towns or neighborhoods called moon
cities or something or moon town or
something like that because they're up
on these hills
but they're steep
steep ass hills and they're in all of
them are built like along the hills
um
and so it was just like up upstairs
upstairs constantly damn that sounds
exhausting that looked awesome though
what was cd about it
i don't he said uh he said scuffed he
said scuffed i didn't i didn't say show
me the seed he said
he said i'll show you the scuff side and
i said that's what i want to see okay
but then
once we got to the top he's like look at
like turn around look out let's go over
because he was in chat
and it was like the best view of busan
it was so beautiful damn
yeah that sounds like it sounds like he
was hiding in an abandoned building that
was supposedly haunted
what this just
taking turns what it's fine
um
and then the next week we went fishing
and i didn't catch anything
that's awesome though
it sounds like don't [ __ ] with cats
where like they tried to geo map where
the killer was because he was posing by
a library or he was this the campers and
they use the maps and they try and do
the followers trail it's like the shiloh
boof thing that 4chan did too
what was that
when he was doing it we will not divide
it or he would not
4chan kept trolling him and so they kept
changing the location to more and more
like private places but then they were
like at one point it was just a shot of
a flag on a wall
and they figured it out based on the sun
and they were like looking up properties
that like jesus his manager owned and
things like that
internet people are crazy this is like
figure it out if you want to
like this is why they're going to figure
out where alana is right now from the
background
yeah
[Laughter]
this is why ready player one was always
unrealistic it's like
they always had them like looking for
all those like what was it keys or
something yeah it was like this wow he
was the first person in eight years to
think about going in reverse yeah it's
like it was all these crazy mysteries
that nobody had solved in ages was like
internet people are crazy they figured
that stuff out when the forums don't
exist
oh
they're outlawed
yeah so like you can hang out as your
avatars but you can't type on a forum
unless all information is lost if you're
not
in conversation
lana confirmed ready player one
apologist right here
i did give that movie like a seven out
of ten and everyone was very upset with
me oh really i didn't get it
when you were too high of a score yeah
everyone was upset ready player one ign
ruby did you did you watch it without
bias did you watch it alone without
anyone influencing you no it was super
biased and i realized that as my first
time
viewing a movie like that um that i was
sitting next to the director oh just the
director
um at the alamo in like the most excited
room of all time because it was the
first time a lot of the public was
seeing it and
that was like the moment where i was
like oh movie reviews people are worried
about game reviews where like the review
is just sitting in their [ __ ]
apartment playing something for ages
there's no hype movie reviews they like
put you in the room with all these
famous people and everyone else in the
room is crying and screaming so like you
get elevated by that experience sure
because as you know all the actors go
over
this was such an honor to be in this
show i can't exactly stand
watching
a new show or a watch party for
something
i've been a part of with the rest of the
crew or actors or their families it's
the worst [ __ ] experience
because
it's screaming and clapping at every
credit so when the name comes up
right
and then it's it's it's did the
laughter's so forced because they're
excited to see themselves or their loved
ones on screen
um it's just like a massive circle jerk
and
i always kill the party when they're
like so what did you think i was like it
was all right
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah apparently i gave ready player 1 a
7.5
and um
i feel like i stand by it everyone like
thought it was garbage but i was like as
an action movie it was pretty fun
there's a scene that i thought was
stupid it was fun
yeah that's the thing like
78 jumping out of the plane
and fighting mech godzilla or whatever
it was was
worth
a seven anyway just that bit and that
shining scene i love that shining oh my
god oh god
something happened
what so about two weeks
ago i had an audition that i had to film
and put on tape and i literally only had
the night to do it
um
and we have a tape recorder
yeah you have to get the vhs done um
so
i'm panicked
i've got no one i can read with
and it dawned on me
that
jacob's nearby and i've never asked
jacob and i need a reader right i need
someone across the the room with the
sides to read against with me so i
thought [ __ ] this let me just let me
just see what happens so i give jacob a
call i don't even go for the text i
break all friendship barriers i go
straight for the phone call wow and jake
it's 1995. absolutely disclosed and it
was his mom it was a house phone as well
it was jacob's mom and i was like can i
speak to jacob please
jacob
rubble i i needed his clothes that i was
completely naked when i picked up the
phone because i just jumped out of the
shower i was like who's calling
i love that that happened that's made my
day i wish you just declared that when i
answered hey rob naked i'm naked jacob
did you also hear the ring go
what is that
sound
yeah everyone's called me in three years
of owning this phone i know it was it
was bizarre i was looking under all like
the wait where did you have your phone
if you were naked a prison wallet
yeah
this is where jacob keeps he puts it in
a plastic bag so you can jack up in the
shower they probably thought my prison
wally but my [ __ ] oh that's what i
thought you meant too yeah yeah oh yeah
okay
that is yeah i'm sorry i missed that
anyway
i'm in a bit of a panic so i asked jacob
and jacob
agrees and
uh he gets to mine i spend the whole
time
uh
waiting for jacob to just like drilling
it drilling it because i just i don't
want to waste his time from drilling the
lines and jacob walks in
walks over looks at the gundams
and then we start talking about some of
the new gundams in the packaging
and we start opening them
and i'm losing daylight
and then we start talking about zeta
gundam
and then we
just
agree i agreed like yeah let's watch
that instead
instead of jacob i didn't listen
jacob's energy was was all play and i
felt that when i walked in and i was
excited to see jacob and show him all
the new stuff
did he keep bouncing
well we we recorded a video to send you
but i don't think it went through no it
did go through oh you saw it yeah it's
time you sent it over the text and so it
was like really small 24 by 40 pixels
yeah it's all like crushed and stuff
it's weird oh i didn't realize
that so we ended up watching a gundam
anime
the whole night and then i fell asleep
yeah yeah then i fell asleep and then um
i didn't get the tape done
and jacob tucked you in you were there
yeah essentially we were hanging out
tell me like about all his like stuff he
was doing with like the your rx 78 that
you're painting and stuff which looks
amazing it looks so good yeah and like
we were just talking stuff and then like
about like 90 minutes into that
conversation you stopped you're like
i'll send you the script
oh yeah you're right yeah but then we
kept going and then we kept going and
then the animes went on and we ordered
food you ordered 24 hot yeah we were
eating chicken sandwiches and then just
watching this just kidding you were
pretending you were going to do work and
then you ordered 24 hot you put on a
gundam
anime just realized i'm kidding i cannot
ask jacob because i can only play with
jacob there can't be business and then
we'll get to the play part like as soon
as jacob walked through the door
there's just i could there was no way i
could then bring it back
yes i was fully prepared to come help
but things just went where they went
john what have you just eaten and why
did you eat like that
why are you so you don't hear the
crunching you look so guilty
is it human flesh
what that doesn't answer any questions
that what this little bag that you've
just held up it's not a bag it's a dutch
sausage oh
delicious
wow it is so oily and delicious they
hang them from strings
and they roll them in flour or something
that's what yourself slice
it contains all the juices
it's so [ __ ] good that sounds amazing
all right
it is amazing and i have a brick of brie
or a wedge of brie
and some uh
come on let me rip this off
never mind it's not coming so you just
put one uh
i thought they were dutch crackers but
it turns out they're italian
i looked at it i went oh fratelli
l'oreal laurier that sounds dutch
so basically you're eating better in
amsterdam in the dam than you were in
korea is my guess
yes
uh
did you have to do a quarantine or
anything in amsterdam and were you good
you were just good
did you have to quarantine because i
know you're quarantined in korea what
was the travel process like for
amsterdam um here's the thing well i
don't know if you guys are the vaccine
only last six months but
with the
with the passport
i have the california like the digital
qr code or whatever
that's all i needed
oh cool
um i got stopped in germany i went
through immigration in germany
and he looked he was like do you have
your negative code test and i went i'm
vaccinated [ __ ]
any and he went ah
yeah wait what are the how do you say
yes in german yeah i think you did
javel
anyways they let me through
uh and then i was kind of like they had
me fill out this form for the
netherlands it was like an entry form
like
affirming that i didn't have any
symptoms and stuff like that and we were
going through and i was like all right
round two of immigration
and i'm rolling because i got my bags
i'm rolling my bags
uh looking around going all right where
is it i go out and it opens up to the
giant lobby of the airport and i was
like
i guess there's no immigrations in the
netherlands you just kept going but i
someone told me that it's because i
already went through it in germany that
i didn't have to go through it
um
but it was fine i just walked out and
then the craziest thing was i went
outside and it was cold
and i got so confused because for the
last three months
uh
korea has been it's summer
where it's very humid and very hot
so i stepped outside and i was like
my body was like what why aren't you
immediately sweating and like like
suffering
uh it was great it was awesome
oh i missed let me tell you the amount
of uh
sweat and suffering that occurred in
nicaragua and also mexico
yeah i might hear about that yeah i
didn't give you guys the context or for
anyone who's like not caught up on all
the videos that i made about this
basically when i was in australia
um
my
visa stamp and my passport expired
that's not the same as my visa expiring
my visa itself was still valid but what
it means is that i was not allowed to
enter the us
with that passport other than as a
tourist i couldn't work it's very stupid
that i have an active visa but i
couldn't enter on it so i had to find a
us embassy somewhere in the world that
would take me
where i could just get the stamp put in
my passport um
so i it was like i had a part-time job
of looking up embassies all over the
world that were taking people like which
ones were available if i had to
quarantine in different countries uh
like what their restrictions were um
most embassies globally are closed only
taking emergency appointments not
yeah because available so i was like
okay i'll go to perth perth has a 14-day
wait time that sucks but still in
australia i'll go to perth uh you have
to apply to enter perth they canceled or
sorry they rejected my application
within 24 hours they were like you're
not allowed in the state
um so then
my last option was sydney because the
camera one doesn't process one visas
there isn't one in brisbane where my
family is and the wait times were till
november or
yeah i just did i and i already with the
november wait time i didn't trust that i
would be able to leave i was like i'm so
sure that if i end up staying here until
november they will change travel
restrictions pushing it and pushing i
will have just moved back to australia
stupid um
you can watch porn in australia yeah
video games oh but only a large breast
to women right isn't that the thing that
was passed
that was a different australia whoa what
was the politician that said it oh
there's no way porn illegally no it
wasn't australia
some politician was like small breasted
women look underage and so that's
illegal only large breasts and women are
allowed to be wow
so porn is absolutely legal but you have
to be over 18 to watch it
which obviously in america
i would have to say that
i actually wouldn't be surprised if the
rules were the same in the u.s
yeah yeah it'd be over 18. is it an
australian porn what noises do they like
in australian you know i don't know
[ __ ] me in the ass mate i don't know if
i've ever seen australia it's a
didgeridoo i don't know if i've ever
seen any i think
it's the same websites because you guys
say like instead of like roll you say
razzers it was like you know come on my
tissues
comment comment on my tizzies what is
that we have a slang for tits
i don't think we do
devastatingly australian's learning for
tips thank you google it's like koalas
or something yeah
just google australian porn and it's
been about 15 minutes no it's knocks
it's actually awesome australia
yeah it's just normal it is knocks
it's an australian time throwback yeah
i think the term homeless bum is gaining
oh never mind that's understood
that's it it's oh yeah
cans is it australian english for for
breasts how's it spelled cans that feels
amazing it is
what about the
what about dick you got a good dick
stuff oh donga is the main one
no it's not you've made that up no
that's absolutely true donga so you
would say what yeah i was gonna say
what's that what's your [ __ ] donghae
in my clackama donna
i think that schlanger is one as well
that's the one that's used in mad max
but yeah she says schlanger yeah well
they also why do you guys call gasoline
guzzling that's what i want to know yeah
yeah so that goes back to what you did
mad max come out
no that's not mad max
no it's australia we call it petrol i'm
sorry
we call it petrol
in korea they call it plastic petrol
oh i guess tech yeah it's still true
interesting
australian porn sounds terrible never
watched it i don't you know it's not
like when you did you only see british
porn in the uk
of course you didn't yeah well yeah but
actually you know
i also watch all porn on mute so when if
it were australian i don't listen to it
it's always muted
yeah and i was like i only had three
years of it before i left when i'm in
vancouver and i'm playing with myself
i never thought of that because there's
so many times where you see the
thumbnail and you go
damn
and then you click in and they're like
i have i have major problems with the
weird people i find it so off-putting
when women in porn just scream
you're like that's clearly not how an
orgasm works and i'm just so aware that
all this is fake so i just mute all of
it and all those phrases like the ego
boosting phrases that the women say to
them sometimes it's super direct things
that
the women do
when they like start breathing and then
they shake a bit
and then they stop i've never seen that
yeah like whatever that is
i've never seen that in real life
yeah
i've never i don't know what the [ __ ]
that one that's tough to achieve
i don't know what that is
you get there one day
um so we have i have some more for you
uh old fella
we call a penis an old feminist
i'm taking old fellow that's it old
fellow's mine
uh wang
a willy and a boomer
so i one of my favorites is a freckle
for another
yeah
yeah um
is a word for vagina wait what yeah
rhymes with foot but with an m mutt i
love that australian porn wants to make
sure that you're over 18 to watch people
talk like they're four-year-olds okay i
don't know that anyone actually talks
like this in australian porn but in any
case back to me being uh unable to leave
australia
yeah so i i
basically like was talking to the
lawyers that i have like on and off this
whole time trying to figure out what to
do and they were like we think you
should stay in sydney and i was like i
think i need to [ __ ] leave sydney
because i was so certain that if i
stayed that eventually
i would be stuck in australia that
happened like two weeks after i left
they mandated that citizens would not be
allowed to leave so
very glad stressful yeah yeah so we're
trying to figure out my other options i
was like could i go to like a country
that would be dope to go to can i like
go to rome why didn't i do that couldn't
the embassy wasn't available i could it
was pretty close to going to jakarta but
then they had a uh another quarantine
mandate thing like i was just looking at
all these countries and seeing all my
options and
the only option the literal only option
was nicaragua
uh and that was because they had an
embassy that had appointments that were
soon
and i could enter without having to
quarantine
um so that you know i was like okay i
guess i'm going to nicaragua my backup
plan was if nicaragua didn't work i was
just going to move to the bahamas like
that was my genuine plan
multiple people about like what a
horrible backup plan i had spoken to a
lot of people and was like listen this
is going to sound insane here's what i'm
trying to do if i can't go to nicaragua
and this doesn't work i'm going to move
to the bahamas for three months and live
there
in nassau while i try to figure out what
the [ __ ] to do and wait for an embassy
to open oh nassau yeah i would have been
sick i'm like kind of sad i didn't get
to move to the point
it's like
one of the smallest countries or
something like that and that's how it's
just the city in the bahamas and it is
it is really small but
but uh it looks beautiful but i know it
is also very unsafe the minute that you
get outside the tourist areas so it
probably would have cost me
like a fair amount of money to stay
there because in your life you wouldn't
be able to leave my life yeah
so nicaragua was like similar it is the
second poorest country in uh central
america
um and you know definitely very
concerned about it and so was everyone
else i remember when i told uh sony that
that's what i was doing i was like i
gotta go to nicaragua they were like
surely there's something else that we
can we can talk to our lawyers and like
see if they can do something because i
imagine sony has very expensive
immigration lawyers i sent them a full
detail of everything that i was doing
and why and they came back and they were
like
no that's
yeah that's what you have to do that is
that is it off you go
so went to nicaragua
um arrived it was wonderful
it actually was quite lovely but arrived
pretty late at night and that's not
ideal um naturally getting from
australia to nicaragua is not the
easiest set of flights
and get a taxi right outside the airport
i did look up a little bit about making
sure that you travel safely because it
is a genuine risk in nicaragua
that
you can get kidnapped if you look rich
and they will make them
make you give them all your money or
whatever um and my immigration team was
very specific about me not saying where
i was on social media because they were
like this is a reality in this country
for foreigners it's not like it's
terrible it's not like i was like scared
all the time or anything but they were
like just better to be safe than sorry
is don't post on social media where you
are because if somebody in nicaragua has
shitty family that could be like she's a
youtuber she probably has a ton of money
that that i could get located and
kidnapped and as we were just saying
with the 4chan thing it's very easy to
figure out where people are
it doesn't require that much effort like
there are a few chain hotels and i don't
think it would be dumb for someone to
make the leap of like she's probably
staying in one of the chain hotels that
she knows that we were at the time i
figured it out
damn all right
how did you not appear rich when you
were wheeling the cyberpunk chair out of
the airport
i do take it with me everywhere yeah
ring like cyberpunk chair yeah
that's that's me yes that was that was a
tough one but i refused to part with it
uh so got in a taxi from the airport
that did have the red around the license
plate which is how you know that they're
valid cabs
and was like okay here's where the hotel
is please take me to this location
and uh
they drive past it
oh
on a highway they just keep going and
it's really late it was like maybe 11 30
or something
and
i was like okay they're probably just
like they need to turn around or
something this is like they just have to
keep going on this road and they have to
turn around
and then
i think
pointed out to them that they'd passed
it and they were like
okay or something but kept going
and then pulled off the highway into
like some side street and then more side
streets and then more side streets and
it was very dark
and then just stopped at one point
uh outside of a different hotel
uh in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere i
would not have had any idea how to get
out of that place but they were like
here you are and i was like no no no no
no no this is not
the hyatt that i'm trying to go to it
turns out that they just misunderstood
and made about okay but
yeah my my stomach
like i was gracious real like can at
first i was like it's fine they're just
going to turn around this is not
happening and then as it got like
further into these several turns i was
like this is [ __ ]
none of this is good this is and and it
occurred to me that
if i were to be in a bad situation where
like someone was trying to
rob me or kidnap me that i have no plan
like i was thinking about okay what's
the plan to what do i do if this happens
literally and they took all your weapons
before you got on the plane exactly so i
didn't have my ak-47s which as you know
i carry with me everywhere in la but i
wasn't allowed to have that in nicaragua
which no actually i think i did see
people walking around up and carrying
guns a couple of times also a lot of
horses just chilling on the roads
just like in the middle of a highway
very strange but yeah i was like that
was the moment that it occurred to me
that i had no [ __ ] plan whatsoever
for if i would get kidnapped i was like
i guess i just give them all my money
and trump i don't die
i jumped straight onto youtube uh
instagram i'd hit live
and it would be like hi i'm being
kidnapped back at the driver back at
myself back in the driver i have always
thought that if that would have happened
and you're making content in an uber or
something
think about the
[Laughter]
i'd love that if you were being
kidnapped
but you can still see the hearts because
i guess that's the only way people can
do something yeah you see the parts that
you see show feet like
well it'll be the little face with a
little tear those would be popping up
yeah
when i had a
stalker in la that i definitely think
that you john and jacob would know about
yes we had to deal with the situation at
the office um
that was my thing with him was like i
was like he's gonna pick me up from
funhouse one day
and i'm gonna end up in the back of the
van
and that's got that's what he wants to
do because i have all all this stuff
where he's like furious that i hadn't
moved in with him and he blamed bruce
for it and [ __ ]
um
it's very intense he's yours yeah he
specifically blamed bruce yeah he was
like bruce won't let you is that what it
is why won't you move in with me my love
that was my plan for that was always
okay the day that he shows up and i get
kidnapped i just live streaming you make
the content
someone see it
i don't know if you have it but there's
those keychain things that it's
basically just a metal
handle with a point
it's not like a spike but it's pointed
like a cone
well i guess it's a spike but it's not a
sharp spike
um and it's great for just crack people
over the skull with
my sister had one a few lady friends i
know had him i don't know i don't think
they ever used them but it's like
it it's just your fist and you just go
but do you get in trouble
uh
so i had peppa spray on my keys my house
keys but then i went to universal and
they were like you can't bring pepper
spray in here and i was like [ __ ] this
also alana would have alana would have
spiked a poor nicaraguan driver who
misunderstood because john's like what
you want to do is you want to get the
[ __ ] thing and you just got jabbed in
the [ __ ] forehead
thankfully nothing bad happened got to
the hotel and i didn't get to explore
nicaragua a whole lot because i was
working every day um so you know still
went out at night occasionally uh we
were right across from a shopping center
so i managed to get
like there was uh uh uh what's it called
um hard rock cafe
like that was like basic america that
started that's actually that started in
nicaragua what people don't realize the
hard work
is that the first one
that's why they're one of the poorest
countries they put all their money
into
this startup worked out okay
yeah it was originally called cafe day
hard rock
um yeah a fair amount of people spoke
english and
uh on the weekend
uh i booked a tour to go to laguna de
apoyo which is basically like this
really big beautiful lake that's chicken
laguna
chicken i did just say apollo didn't i
yeah
it's a chicken lagoon
no it is a poyo
it's a
lagoon national reserve and it is it is
basically
uh a crater
of a volcano because nicaragua has 19
active volcanoes
it's a really cool landscape because
jacob is already picturing the mustafa
system yeah i know how his brain works
it's already a must-have system yep it's
very neat though um did go to an active
volcano that was my second time going to
an active volcano you throw something
inside it no super far away like the one
that i went to the first time was in
vanuatu where we were allowed very close
my stepdad got burned on his hand
from like it she just crashed at him how
close were you also super close like
i was dangerously close it sounds like
yeah because vanuatu is a pretty small
country very close to australia where
there are essentially no rules
whatsoever
really like you see just people just
hanging out holding machetes and smiling
at you all the time
um because like they're just like
chopping down trees or something and
they're just like
i'm sorry me and jacob would have got
burnt if we were there because we've
been doing the high ground speech
absolutely it's true um
about the the volcano in vanuatu was the
bugs that
inhabit an area around a volcano are the
weirdest [ __ ] [ __ ] you've ever oh
yeah really strange bugs what and also
the same round is like purple it's
[ __ ] weird why the bug strange
that climate is the heat yeah it's a
climate dog yeah the same with
underground lava spouts or something
like that
like up in the arctic
there are these live spouts on the
ground floor
of the ocean oh yeah the ocean ones yeah
it's like watching attenborough right
now yeah
that's how he speaks there's they they
found them
up like you know near the pole or
whatever down under all the ice
and uh
there was just this thriving ecosystem
because around the heat
they
you know uh world could threat
yeah and the water is like hundreds of
degrees it's also stuff too a lot of i
think it's sulfur
they have there's there are a lot of
gases near volcanoes as well but um the
the volcano look at what it was called
well it's kind of like the
lava fleas that the guys are riding on
in those establishing shots when they're
walking through mustafar remember
they're on those big bugs shut the [ __ ]
up
back me up for a little quick shot
i kind of want you just to take the heat
from john because he seems hostile
towards star wars references i have
never seen star wars it was uh the
messiah volcano
um which
apparently for a really long time
uh when anyone would visit it uh they
they actually thought it was a gateway
to hell you actually formally referred
to it as like death's door or the
gateway to hell the mountain oh
no it is really cool looking because uh
in part it's like it really is like you
know a big crater and a smaller crater
and then a circle but it has an active
lava river
uh which means that
while there is always lava usually what
i've seen like the one in vanuatu was
just like solid how you imagine it like
sure it's big and glowing but it's kind
of just solid like it's sort of bubbling
but not really moving whereas
messiah uh is flowing like it looks like
a river that's going from left to right
underneath the mouth yeah it was [ __ ]
cool
i'm so sorry to interrupt i just got a
text message from jacob and it's a
picture of a star the thing
i have a lava fleet
for [ __ ] sake
similarly
when i was in jeju which was in between
uh
seoul and busan it was just for a week i
went because jeju is a volcanic island
uh they have no the beaches are just
black jagged rock yeah um
but they had these lava tubes that i
went and explored
uh it was like a tour i didn't like
sneak in there
but they're just giant like
you know like
60 feet high and around
and they're underground lava tubes where
lava just flowed and flowed
so i mean that it's
this way
yeah that's like the thing that i just
said it's really it's like you related
same experience
crazy look at us relating
around the world all around the world
wait yeah alana you keep saying the
first volcano was where
vanuatu where's that
uh it's like a three-hour flight from
australia oh okay the first volcano ever
yeah
where is it um it is yeah i mean it's
very close to australia uh
to papua new guinea kind of
looks like it's you're right it's right
in the middle i don't believe you
of oceana
volcanoes in the philippines
there is actually there's a crazy video
i think from a few years back this one
just like exploding while people are on
a boat and like the shock wave just like
hits the boat and it's just like
it's crazy
yeah cool
isn't that one there was a volcano i
mean
it's common knowledge but there was that
volcano that exploded
back in like
1890 or something and it looped the
world seven times it was so loud
that sounds insane you guys don't know
about that no
it's like a it's like a cacao name or
something like that
there are currently like i think it's
three volcanoes going off
in um alaska
right now
yeah oh yeah which is pretty concerning
what's pompeii
well that's supposed to be like the most
devastating one that was the devastating
one i think italy was
is it italy i think it's italy my
geography is terrible i shouldn't be
able to
like came on them so fast who did he
came on slides
the volcano came on
it was him been over and then there was
like a little spout coming out of his
penis that also fossilized no
no that didn't happen he just looks like
he's masturbating they're also like
people kissing because they were
basically just
how quick were they wiped out they
couldn't even pull away from the chin i
mean there were people climbing away it
was really well preserved yeah maybe he
like mistook his climax for the volcano
eruption he thought it was like one of
the same it's the best climax yeah
but i don't know i don't know anybody
[ __ ] maybe there's a lot of people
like laying down dead yeah so the
philippines was mount pinatubo i
remember once i was jacking off uh-huh
this was
pre-phones so i had to go
i was obviously i was
a teenager so i was living at home with
my folks and i went snuck downstairs
closed everything went into the where
the computer was in the computer room
and uh
yeah put some headphones on and started
beating it i don't know big maps jpegs
whatever the hell i was looking at
headphones that's dangerous my friend
i know because when i finished and i got
up all the doors were open
oh no people just passing through
oh great i've never addressed it and i
know that my parents don't watch this
podcast because i would be mortified to
be like which one of yous came
downstairs and just saw me
well did they have to see you
like couldn't is it possible nobody came
down this was before everyone had these
giant computer chairs and they heard all
the grunting too there was the old
school computer
they would have seen my underpants
what if they just didn't pass you though
they had to
what do you mean past me i was in a room
so someone's walked in i opened the door
oh i thought the door
why would i leave doors open if i was
gonna adjust
they opened and they went
yeah and shot and then slowly backed
away yeah
jesus
oh buddy i'm so sorry so i understand
how the pompeii man
he might have had headphones on and not
known the volcano okay the lava was
preserving him from behind
this was your personal pump this is
is the least italian sounding word i've
ever like
what if you say pompeii
yeah well the volcano is a puppy
wasn't it it was like vesuvius pompeii
predates italy doesn't it like
i don't remember i don't know what year
this is a travel show right
yeah but we don't claim to be informed
about travel we just talk about it
comments
so everything we get wrong they'll
correct us very civilly in the comments
who doesn't definitely yeah yeah doug
yeah
um i don't know if it pre-dates it's a
masturbation yeah uh amsterdam oh yes
yes you don't have to masturbate here
because
the
eagles
the canals are spread just as wide as
the legs
okay
are you saying that people they're
promiscuous if we're getting cd are we
talking about we're gonna we're gonna
talk about red light district right
yeah okay i'm getting excited again okay
there we go
i haven't been yet but what i've done
is i've made a list of all the things
that i can do
and then we will i think we should
discuss it and then i'll go do those
things well i'm not going to make you
spend your time in amsterdam as a pony
for my i am
sorry
but before that
i do have to tell you that i went to the
lego store today tight this is what this
is as good as porn
i'm going to be doing uh i've been
i have like a goal that once we reach
the goal on my stream i'm going to get
high and build
legos nice okay um and so i went and uh
it was really awesome it was like lego
land where they have just crazy
sculptures built at lego and stuff so
cool um but there were a few things
there that i think you guys would like
one alana they have a giant three
thousand piece batwing
holy [ __ ] i own that yeah that's awesome
you wear that one
eighty nine thousand piece batwing the
batman 89 batwing
i don't [ __ ] know is it from batman
89 did it look like tim burton's one is
it the round batwing i don't know it had
a bat on it what kind of [ __ ] travel
show is this
i've got that one
alana you're out of focus by the way
yeah it's fine
also
a
an episode two republic gunship yeah
that was very large and it's like 350
euros oh jacob you have it it's in my
closet right now oh my god 1989.
somebody's going oh my god i can't wait
to tell them about that jacob john's
more wrong then because that's the one
he's talking about so he's wrong even
about the amount of pieces j john is
wrong about the amount of pieces in that
batwing unless there is a 3 000 piece
batwing that bat wing is how many pieces
200 2 000 20 2 300 2 300. i was rounding
up
and last but not least this one confused
me
it's darth vader's meditation chamber
it's the oh yeah a playset
yeah wow
which one are you gonna build
um
it was hard to decide because all the
star wars ones were very big or very
small yeah um
and there was one i saw that i thought
was pretty cool because it was an
off-road buggy that you download a lego
technic app
and you can drive it around oh yeah cool
but it was a very simple build that he's
like oh that'll only take you an hour
it's like oh well
well the jacob has it behind him and
i've built it too the razor crest
oh the razor crest how long did that
take it took six hours
six hours five hours i did it i did it
on a stream um yeah i'm much more
simpler than you
yes very stream
stream sized i think yeah you think yeah
and it's not the worst priced i don't
it's probably kind of everywhere right
now you could probably get it pretty
easily well i you guys know that i
probably one of my least favorite
experiences was watching the mandalorian
what so
i'm just joking i love man
we watched it didn't we watch it like in
a la and a big bear we would we in our
little airbnb we like watched the last
episode of mandalorians oh yeah we did
we like did you know we caught up yeah i
think we were like before we went to
meet up with you guys the next day
it was like oh you're not allowed to i
hadn't seen it not allowed to talk about
it that's why i didn't know yeah yeah
that's what that's right that's what it
was we couldn't talk about the finale
yet because
i wanted to wait until i could watch it
on my tv back yeah
it wasn't the best tv but it was still
fun but then someone told me
i saw a tweet
from one of our mutuals that was like i
knew it the second i saw red five and i
wanted to smash my [ __ ] phone
i remember when we were there though we
were talking about remember we watched
like the deep fake video where somebody
put like made luke look better yeah
um oh recorder digital yeah isn't that
the guy they hired too yeah they hired
that guy
yeah he put harrison ford on the young
solo
yeah he's very impressive oh this just
looks amazing i'm confused
what's happened
no i just don't know what you guys are
talking about
let's do this this is pre-corridor
digital it's like a whole channel where
he does deep fakes this guy does things
and stuff yeah yeah and then ireland
yeah yeah because he was so good he put
jack nicholson on bill hader's face yeah
stuff like that what um okay what sexy
stuff have you done
uh i've been reading a lot of stephen
king while sitting in cafes overlooking
canals
so you haven't hit the road that sounds
awesome though have you gone window
shopping
i have not got a window shut i went to
the red light district during the day
and there was one
uh
escort or i don't even know if they're
escorts because they don't escort you
anyway anywhere they just have beds in
their
weird little studios they escort your
jizz out your bullets i guess they're
just sex workers i don't know
um i don't know what the term is but she
was standing
with the window open just kind of like
slouched
um
and she looked to be maybe like
45 50 with a lot of uh plastic surgery
done
and she had like giant norks
uh with just a black strip
like bikini that was just a straight
line
and i was like whoa
whoa
but i didn't see anybody else what's the
prices
uh so that i've been looking into
because i'm doing another fundraiser
on my stream
where
uh it's 160 euros an hour for the out
calls which there's the
in the studio where you go
i don't know what that's called but out
call is the term for where they when
they come to come to you yeah and so 116
hour 160 euros an hour
so
i have this ongoing thing where once we
raise 160 it adds either an hour or an
escort so my goal is to get three
escorts for two hours and i'm gonna do a
game show yes on stream
that sounds awesome that's very good
the link to raise money it's on it's my
stream labs donation it's all my it's
when i stream you can start
i am i want to make i don't how do i
make sure this doesn't go towards
[ __ ] lego i want it to go to it
it will go to the hookers
lego subs
the actual direct donation is escorts
because i'm not getting any of that
escort money it's going straight to the
escorts yeah yeah of course [ __ ] yeah i
feel like you're gonna have to make sure
that you
tell them ahead of time they're being
broadcasted though right no i'm gonna
hide the camera i don't feel like
listen i don't want to have sex with you
i just want to role play a game show i
want to wear your skin here cheat
towards that part of the room
don't worry about it no i feel like
you're going to have columns because i
feel like there's a significant amount
of people who will say no to that yeah
being live on camera yeah because
you're saying what they do for a living
and then you're broadcasting them to an
audience they're gonna give a [ __ ] they
might though they might they're stopped
the netherlands it's not underground
it's like you can
have it as a profession does that mean
[ __ ] windows they probably don't have
the the stigma that we're used to where
they aren't ashamed
yeah exactly
well i still you still gotta ask him you
definitely still have to always drop no
yeah of course
yeah because otherwise that's like
silence of the lamb [ __ ]
this guy's called three of us go
straight to murder and he's role playing
a game show
yeah and what is that weird like
reflection coming out out of that
[Laughter]
yeah just i think you're crazy talking
to somebody because you're talking to
your chat the whole time
uh do you have any other plans john that
we can look forward to
yeah
so
um
i do have to tell you uh my my host is
super cool
the first thing
he like
he sho he brought me in he's like all
right here's your place we got like a
washing machine here
uh this is like i have like a an alexa
that you can
no nothing alexa
nothing
um
that you can use play music he's got
speakers he's like oh and oh oh give me
the number of my uh dealer and you know
he's got everything like any drugs you
want wow
okay
and he's like i'll send you the menu and
he sent me the menu is heroin on it
no
but do you want to hear what's on the
menu yeah absolutely definitely okay um
is it all legal he won't get in trouble
right
it's not legal but it's not no one
really cares
that's the other thing weed isn't legal
here it's just tolerated really i didn't
yeah i would have assumed that it was
legal right yeah
okay first off
pink cocaine party truck
pink cocaine is dyed pink okay it's just
dyed pink yeah uh ecstasy blue spongebob
oh
it's a xc pill is a [ __ ] that's blue and
it's shaped like spongebob oh my god um
2cb pink nasa i have no idea what that
is but there's an emoji of a rocket next
to it cool um ketamine a bunch of
ketamine a punch mdma speed
and then here's the sketchy part
ghb
which is roofies
um and i mentioned this to someone but
then they were like i know someone that
does ghb recreationally they just roofie
themselves
yeah i guess okay maybe if it's in
smaller quantities you get high off of
it or something i don't know if it calms
you down or something uh yeah maybe it
is a hallucinogenic
and funnily enough pink rocket 2cb is a
song
well there you go i like how they make
it yeah they have all these designer
drugs that i've never heard of four fma
silver tml
can they do you find out if they can get
us a jar jar heroin different kind of
cocaine sounds oh
what is jar jar heroin it's heroin it's
just dyed green
[Laughter]
me and jacob
diazepam and kamagra also available
they only take cash or bitcoin
of course
apparently 2cb is sold as a sexual
enhancement drug that improved libido
and
impotence otherwise
where you just have a boater the whole
time
you are truly a game show god john smith
yeah thank you get that
fresh speaking of
drugs
um elana and jacob were in vegas and i'm
assuming doing drugs together
we did go to vegas yes jacob it was your
first time in vegas since you were 13
yes i don't even remember how old i was
but like i'd only got with my family
like years and years and years ago and
um jacob yeah when you went with your
family did you go to the m m factory yes
so did i absolutely yeah i feel like
everybody brings their kids to vegas is
like oh look at all we'll go get a
shitload of m m's i can segue again
yeah jacob speaking of your family can
you share a story you told me yesterday
about your pups to john please about my
my who your your dad
had a
injured himself he had an injury story
though
i want you to share with john because i
nearly fell off the [ __ ] boat when
you told me
i don't remember how this came up
i think i just might have just brought
it up we were talking about how my dad
um tore his achilles running from a
hummingbird
yeah mr fullerton himself very athletic
man
um and that's how you got jacob ladies
and gentlemen was he soaked in nectar or
something
no
so i think i was in i was i was uh in
the other room just playing video games
or something and uh outside our front
door was like a hanging planter that uh
on one of the little vines there's a
hummingbird nest with tiny little eggs
in it so i just one day jacob hope that
i can write a character as good as you
oh yeah that's
luck
you know i aspire to this level of
perfection so i was playing video games
i think my dad was like going like
taking one of the dogs out to pee or
something in the front yard i guess he
uh spooked the mother hummingbird that
was in that nest so sort of buzzing
around his head
so i think he just turned and ran back
inside i just heard it like a a body hit
the floor
oh no
when did he how did he tear it was it he
turned too fast or something is like
well he was also playing with those
ribbons you know like oh yeah
yeah that's where i learned it from
but yeah oh god yeah i think they don't
see nobody ever tears their achilles
doing something crazy it's like oh get
out of bed my achilles ripped or
whatever i was uh playing basketball in
mexico
and there was like a small ditch in the
dirt and i rolled my ankle and it hurt
for two straight weeks oh no
i just tried to jump and then my whole
you know how like you know you got your
leg and you got your foot just my whole
foot
and sounds gross it hurt pretty bad and
i was like i'll be fine this will be
fine and then it was bruised and i i
yeah
you're gonna be [ __ ] up forever you're
getting you're getting old i know yeah
i just i heard a body crumple the floor
and i went in there
he was just ah
oh i think i told him the hummingbirds
and i was like what happened it's like a
hummingbird came at me he's like son put
the [ __ ] dancing ribbons away i don't
want to ever see you play with these
ribbons
insane oh jacob
oh my god that's amazing but like
it was hard it's the hummingbird part
it's the hummingbird is it's got to be
one of the most
harmless birds yeah yeah you know if it
was very small you could swap one and
kill it yeah if it attacked you it would
probably just shatter
it has though isn't there a bakery named
after it
a hummingbird bakery
yeah like the famous bakery is a
hummingbird i'm sure
famously uh created by jacob's dad
yeah that's what he did ever since
that's amazing yeah i don't know vegas
though yeah yeah yeah jacob i mean
we potted ways at some point in the
evening and then i had to get a very
drunk
friend who i will choose not to name
right to respect his [ __ ] very drunk
ass
yeah to the hotel vomit what was their
profession
doesn't matter
what is their height you know what
actually i could say they're a person
who does uh they're a content creator
and then that wouldn't be the same
that's what i'm saying
yeah so that's because it was terrible
we're not going to detail anything other
than my shoes were covered in vomit
autumn got vomit inside of her purse
yeah this is all after i left
all over the bed we actually got kicked
out of the bar that we were in because
they were like he's drunk and needs to
leave and we were like no no he's fine
and then we looked and we were like oh
he's a ninja
it was ninja yeah um so that happened
but you left before that i think yeah it
was that was a fun night because we were
it was a good night but bruce just kept
[ __ ] giving everyone tequila shots
and we were all like please and they
were stopped they were like doubles
because they didn't have shots
and i think tara pawns went off to john
holland oh yeah that was and i was like
how could i do that because we were all
hanging out and it was just like
i think you captured it great in like an
instagram video you posted at one point
is we were just hanging out and then we
looked over and john holland is standing
there we're like it's john holland by
people he was just there too
no he was just there
that's okay he's not like he'd be close
buds with bruce i don't think but it was
lovely to see him yeah
john holland's always going to vegas
panama all the time
he's way too cool for all of us yeah and
it's just so funny to see him yeah but
yeah uh we were only there for like
a day
uh day in and day out for the weekend it
took us three hours to get there and
then
five to six hours on the way back yeah a
long way because everybody was coming
back from vegas sunday um i never asked
you i don't think how was the you went
to see the shock
oh yeah the next morning because i was
like
i was so tired and hungover from just
the entire first day of us being there
and then i was just like tara we're
gonna go to the shark reef before we
leave
in mandalay bay yeah yeah
what is that
it's a it wasn't in our hotel but in the
mandalay bay
um because we were staying at excalibur
naturally nice yeah
but in mandalay bay there's a big like
aquarium that's actually really cool
they've got like giant sharks and stuff
yeah so yeah we had to go there all
after eating um
this hey i you john you mentioned how in
korea
a lot of restaurants like you can only
eat for like groups and stuff yeah and
the most this is the most relatable
thing i've had to korea is eating a
pooka befo at oh
yeah i thought that you did that
i i absolutely regretted
after that did you sit at the pope table
no i i wish
breakfast oh boo
is like a shitty italian chain i don't
know why i just said it i sounded indian
when i said it look at the people
right well but they only serve like
their smallest servings are for like
three people yeah it's family style yeah
that i i hadn't been to a buccaneer in
ages so tara and i just like had to
pound this beige ziti
for a five hour drive home i was in
agony for like two days
yeah it's a lot but i mean how did it we
can't just leave it
how did you feel about vegas in general
as an adult like you were there for a
good amount of time i always feel like
if you there for longer than three days
it gets
yeah i mean being able to be there and
like
drink
was was great and actually like hang out
with friends and stuff instead of like
following my parents around to the
eminem factory
or whatever the heck was swimming and uh
because what we went to
the first day was um for bruce's
birthday we were at mandalay bay at our
like outside beach like fake beach
did you go for a swim
i walked into the wall i just like
waited around the water like that's
right i was sitting in the wave pool by
myself at one point and i watched you
like sort of walk over you know again
jacob
and you just like kind of put your feet
in and then did a few circles and then
left
oh i didn't know you were watching that
whole thing i was watching what happened
it was actually very strange to figure
out what you're doing it was so hot and
like
i uh i ordered like like a mule and you
know you always expect a mule to come in
like a little
little mud copper cup yeah a little
copper cup but it came in like this
plastic like
a giant cup that was like this tall and
filled to the
brim yeah so i was trashed and it was
like 110 degrees oh my god
we were in that cabana that trapped all
the heat and humidity and stuff so like
i was just standing there like why is my
heart padding so fast it's probably all
the sugar at this berry mule i'll just
go walk into the water
yep that sounds it sounds like you guys
had a great time in vegas we did have a
good time we also um like i uh this
happens to me frequently but realized
that i was way too tired uh at maybe
like
5 30 and so i left to take a nap before
dinner which was planned for 8 30.
um
and i was waiting for stefan lawrence
yeah i was waiting for stefan lawrence
because we were in the same hotel like
goddess and uber but everybody's uber's
canceled like i managed to get ours okay
but we were still 20 minutes late and
then bruce and autumn had to walk
because they had tried calling three
uh ubers and they all cancelled
um where'd it go uber like basically we
had this nice dinner planned for bruce
that i had to just guess what people
would eat and then just order it hoping
that they'd show up yeah what it was it
was a disaster the other problem was
like whoever play on the dinner picked a
time that was 30 minutes before it
closed before the kitchen closed
really yeah which we didn't know
yeah
it's too early for a kitchen to close
isn't it especially in vegas because it
was inside of caesar's palace like why
would they close that up
it was really weird but it was we picked
that place because everywhere else
couldn't take the amount of people that
we had 16 i think but the other problem
was a lot of the reason we were going to
boo
i know we could have gotten just like a
couple
bowls of pasta would have served 12
people yeah
but the other problem was
all these things with the ubers and
stuff we are all in the same like
cluster of hotels that were on the
opposite side of the strip
so there's a handful of us that had like
decided oh we'll walk it was like a 35
minute walk
in the heat
oh no it sounds like fun wish i was
invited
i wish
yeah
yeah i feel like there weren't like that
many shenanigans otherwise other than
you know someone who will not be named
vomiting a lot um yeah did nothing crazy
happen
no
that bar where you're right
that's a crazy juggling and stuff and
they pulled out a trombone occasionally
yes they did pull out a trombone every
so often which was sick
and i kept being like do you think he
actually knows how to play that or or
could i just pick that up and do it so
we asked tara who naturally has our
masters in
music
yeah i don't know that's how
you say it
um and she was like no you could pretty
much just kind of blow into one of those
things and you'd be all right but he
probably does play it
he needed a good immature we also
traveled somewhere as a group john
where the
vipers room viper rooms viper
we went to the johnny depp's club
i've never been there he did no to see
terry say it like john went with you but
um john we're just actually now at this
point telling john things he's missing
out on binding yeah we're telling you
something
we did uh in fact jacob invited a big
group of us to go see tara play at the
viper room nice it's so weird i feel
like i've invited almost nobody but
everybody showed up
just because i actually only saw it
because you reshared her instagram story
yeah i think i did that and i was just
like i'll see who shows up
it's like um yeah a handful of people
folks from work like ryan i think was
having the time of his life
what is he not yeah
um because tara had her banned a loser
parade were playing
there with a bunch of other bands and
they were good and uh yeah they were
really good very very last band that
played
but i brought that energy back we did
take a good
group photo we did um that let me just
pull this up sorry audio
i'll post it somewhere i just want to
show john it's so nice to see him i'm so
glad alana that you picked up on what i
was throwing out so that you would segue
into this this is perfect
this is
see the four of us yeah
that's john in the front there
it's me and rahul and uh lawrence in the
back lawrence is back there jacob there
so really got a nice photo of the
podcast creek wow
and we want that to be
the thumbnail of this video the cover
image
that i actually pull it from his tag is
andrew it was his birthday that day he
was the lead singer uh yeah he was a
parade and i think we're really good and
also one of his strings broke during the
set and they just played on damn that's
badass yeah he was cool everybody was a
guitar just handed it to them like here
use this guitar instead yeah uh can i
confess to you guys
my story vegas yeah
yes i've never told anybody this
is so
embarrassing oh should i stop recording
or
no it's fine i want the world to know i
like airing out my
skeletons
so that it can never come back on me
um so i went to vegas with my family
again but i was
over 21 it was
uh
we did it for
either christmas or thanksgiving because
uh or no thanksgiving was when we moved
my brother out after he got divorced and
then we did christmas
that same time we did christmas in vegas
for the same kind of reason that things
were weird and so we did christmas in
vegas for some reason
um and i ended up going out with my
brother and sister my brother dipped
early
and so while i was walking around my
sister super drunk and we're walking
down the street
and this dude walks by my sister's like
hey
and they start chatting
and then
she's like do you want to go to the
strip club and the guy's like hell yeah
um and for some reason this all just
happened while you were just standing
there yeah yeah yeah okay um and for
some reason i was like
i need to go with my sister to make sure
she's okay but she's like four years
older than me
and like i could have just dipped
but it was like she met this random
stranger on the street and she's going
to strip with him like i should probably
stick around
okay
how did that guy do that because in my
head a dude saying hey to me on the
street never my sister said hey she's my
sister yeah my sister was the yeah the
predator
was the aggressor he was the prey
and it was your sister's suggestion to
go strip club yes he's just having a
great night yeah he's clearly saying
no
john go away right
no
my sister invited me and i was like i
don't know
she's like no come on
i was like all right
um and so i went and i was so
uncomfortable and i had
uh
i didn't have i didn't bring any fancy
pants so my dad had loaned me like these
like dress slacks
so i was wearing his dress slacks
um
and we go and we're sitting there and
like
because we're all very trunk my sister's
like i'm going to buy you a lap dance
john
and i was like
awesome
yeah and so
then like this pretty lady walked by and
i was like i'll get a lap dance from her
i guess
and so she took me back into the
vip room or like the booth or whatever
um and i left my sister in that random
guy
uh and then she's dancing for a little
bit and then she like leans over
whispers in my ear she goes i'm gonna
make you come
and she say it like that yeah and i was
like
yeah and i was like
what
because i was i've never been to a
stripper before i didn't know
that that was like a thing
and so i was like
what she's like i'm gonna make you come
i was like
i'm stuck like okay
wait so this was your first time this is
my first time ever in a strip club i was
like 22
um
and so
she rubbed around until it happened but
here's the thing i was wearing boxers
i was wearing boxers in my dad's dress
pants
so i stood up
and it immediately starts going down my
leg oh my god it's pumping so i
and so i'm like oh god how am i going to
do this and i walk out and my sister and
the dude are just like
i was going to tell you
it was small she's already in the [ __ ]
out of here and i just went later sis
and then i walked out and then i had to
basically just i don't remember what i
said my dad was like
bathroom
i was freaking out this is like a
post-nut moment like you like your brain
is not in the right place your brain's
not in the right moment yeah so i
basically just lied to my dad and was
like can i like i love these pants can i
have these pants
and he's like sure
oh my god
this is personal
that was that
was that the first time you got like a
hand jobby thing
oh no i don't know so you'd already had
like a hand job yeah yeah yeah yeah
and stuff like that that wasn't the
first interaction yeah okay cool
it was my first experience with sex work
yeah
with a doctor she did a great job by the
time did you like give her a tip
no my sister paid
that's right i forgot your sister paid
for you
thank you john the reason i asked that
is because the first the first woman i
was with
uh-huh
where
they were naked or topless the first
boobs i ever felt
was a stripper
at the game station which is the uk
version of gamestop
uh christmas
cool where you see strippers
well we were i was 18 or 17
and our work do we went out for drinks
in a town a little place called watford
and i you know the manager decided
we should all go to the strip club now
and i'd never
at that point been with a woman i hadn't
such a hr violation oh yeah massively
his name's dan you used a game station
wembley you can go sue him he's a prick
so we went
uh
and that dance was i was like i didn't
i'd never been to a strip club before so
went in and she happened to be american
which was weird anyway
um had a dance never seen boobies before
uh remember thinking they were cold
which was a surprise to me
when she put them on my face
they were like refreshing like i was my
face was warm the boobs were cooling oh
okay i remember that i was like oh
that's cool okay and um i didn't come
because she wasn't trying to make me but
she could have very easily if if she had
said to like she said to john i'm gonna
make you come
but she didn't say any of that um and
then
i
i only had like 20 pounds left or 25 but
whatever it was
that's all i had and and i had used it
on one dance and i fell in love
instantly
and then i was out the side
selling things to my co-workers for cash
like that i was like you know the x-men
special edition i have i'll sell it to
you right now 10 pounds and i was
selling stuff that's the episode of your
enthusiasm
is it larry david's dad
oh the with the hand job yeah
he wanted to buy her a toaster and then
he decides he's going to buy her a
toaster
yeah i so i did sell some stuff i sold
some like limited edition things to
other co-workers for money
she was like [ __ ] this guy again yeah
how long did that matter she didn't i
still still didn't know so i was like
i'll be right back and then you ran out
the door to like get to your friend yeah
don't go anywhere i don't want to pay
you the door like hunched over
don't put the bikini back on you know
what i mean i want a full song with
topless yeah keep those it's cold
those tits
i guess i don't like strip clubs i
haven't been to very many i've been to
three i think
john's sister could all take us all
i used to frequent
strip clubs a lot
it to the point where
in
vancouver with it was first name basis
you should stop talking alana do you
i mean yeah so my 18th birthday i
went out that's because that's when you
can drink in australia so we go out and
go to a bar whatever group of friends
and i drunkenly decided to go to a strip
club
first time i was legally allowed to do
that so it was on my 18th birthday 24th
of august um
and did so
and i for whatever reason in my head
probably because of movies
thought that they only took their tops
off so i was like i'll see some boobs
it'll be a great time they'll dance
whatever
um they got fully naked
and
they stripped there's no delicate way to
to really put it but there were just
some some female genitalia on display
that i personally found to be very
unappealing
uh oh in what way describe it for a
second i prefer everything is like a
snowflake i have to
disclose my personal
uh vagina preferences
did it look like a pastrami sandwich i
don't want to get into it okay
everybody's beautiful etc there was just
some things that i found to be
unappealing how are their freckles stop
it
razor burn
one of them looked
uh one of them how many vaginas did she
have a few actually but there was one
that like was visibly like like a hydra
a bit dirty looking
um like it had like just kind of bits of
dirt on it
um
white like dingleberry like toilet paper
i don't really know but all i know is
that i was like shocked like i i really
thought that i was gonna go in there and
i was gonna see some boobies wobbling
and then i was gonna have a great time
and then people were fully naked and i
didn't expect it and i was like
i don't know it's gonna be a very
sobering experience yeah um the last
time i was ever in a strip club and i'll
go faster this one because we got to get
to amsterdam uh quiz show
um last time i was in a strip club
uh i lived with these dudes that i i've
always described it as frat boys that
were never in a frat they all went to la
film school but they were super broly
and they were always like let's go to
strip club
um
and so i went with them a few times they
would go all the time i went with them
like three times i think
and one time my friend disappeared for
two hours and it turned out that he had
put he'd gone to the take a [ __ ] and he
pushed so hard that he passed out
oh my god and he was passing on the
toilet for two hours oh my god
but the last time i went
i went and the first two times i hadn't
got a dance but i was like you know i'll
i'll get a dance whatever
um i'm the only person here that has a
job so i can afford it
um they were all out of work uh
and so there was this girl named jersey
that was dancing i was like sure her
and uh
shh
god
we go back
uh and she's dancing and going
i think this booth there's something
that smells in this booth this weird
somebody kind of smells
um and then she got fully naked
and she was dancing i was like man what
is that smell
and then she turned around
and bent over
and she was prairie dogging
like she really had to go to the
bathroom
and it immediately
i and i of course that was like five
minutes into the 20 minute dance
and i literally was just like
oh
but then i couldn't get up
and i just literally sat there going
oh god oh no
oh my god
it was she wasn't turtle heading by the
way it wasn't out
okay but it was like it kind of opened
but you could tell oh like
it was starting to go the gates were
starting to open and i've never gone
back to a strip club
ever again holy [ __ ] oh that was the
last time that was the last time the
first time i went is also a relatively
short story
i was for a friend's bachelor party and
uh i was there and so was there was only
one other girl who uh is a lesbian
um and for some reason me being there
while everybody was drunk meant that i
had i don't know ten men
like almost cry
to me like i became a therapist for
every single one of them individually
where i was hearing about all these
problems that
i didn't even know some of them the ones
that i'm good friends with were fine but
the ones that were like middling just
like got us just went and got a lap
dance and then came back and like
dumped all of their personal problems on
me it was [ __ ] bizarre two of them
had to apologize the next day
because they
i i was like something about like
vulnerability in that situation made me
they just i decided i was a therapist
and just came at me with like all of
their issues
one of them
went hard on like insulting one of my
personal friends like like a close
friend was like she's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
man and i was like i don't know why
you're having this conversation what do
you think is gonna happen here like do
you think i'm gonna support any of this
like it was just it was a wild
experience and i was like okay never go
to a strip club with which entirely
dudes yeah and a lesbian ever again it
was a bad call everybody just got sad
yeah
yeah that's the thing strip clubs is
fun time it's very dark time
i've gone in a long time but i remember
so it was just a very random image
that's burnt i was trying to think of
strip club stories the only one i have
is real brief
but
there was no
um like lap dances happen on a separate
area right they go behind the curtain
and stuff and you're not supposed to
touch or anything it's just you know
they dance for you and this particular
place had
like registered masseuses
like you know so like for patrons they
would they would just come up and they'd
be like hey would you like a neck
massage so while you're sitting there
you know you have that in certain places
and clubs and stuff they would you know
i've never experienced that but go on
i feel like i'm trying to think where
else i've seen i've seen it in other
other stuff we go to regular bars and
he's out here on some next level
[ __ ] it was like it wasn't like it
wasn't like a fancy area and they're
bringing you chris jowl and rubbing your
belly
this wasn't a fancy place but they had
like you know the the masseuse belt with
the the oils and stuff as well like that
anyway this is not normal take your [ __ ]
off love
nothing's relatable
yeah you would you would sit there and
you know that she would walk around to
different tables and
and offer massages
and i went to the bar to get some drinks
and the guy i was there with
uh the masseuse was talking to him
and then
i looked back and he was just sucking
her tits
oh okay
wasn't a dancer
just a registered masseuse
and he was just sucking her tits on the
dance floor was she okay with it
yeah
it was definitely
uh consensual but it was just a sight
that i it went from
you know zero to a hundred
from me going to the bar looking back
not thinking he was talking to a dancer
he was talking to a registered masseuse
and then just sucking her norks yeah
i guess he must have just asked her
something well yeah i mean that's
something i've heard a lot of not a lot
but like
uh if a stripper is single and a cool
guy comes in
you know they're cool with stripping so
they're cool with dudes coming in to
strip clubs
uh sometimes they find love
uh in their lives it's definitely a
thing yeah yeah i've uh i think i've
spoken you guys before about one of my
favorite subreddits is sex workers only
where it's like the name would apply
only sex boys are allowed to post
and they have just very genuine
conversations with each other and
sometimes it'll be i have this client
that i really like and i can't stop
thinking about him and i know that i
can't do anything but i really [ __ ]
like him i asked him in his ear well
i told him i was going to make him
[Laughter]
they give each other advice basically
and that's like the whole point of it
only being sex workers allowed in there
and you look wonderful it's like yeah
i've been i've been in love with one
before as well you just can't do
anything about it can you can you look
up one right now and give like give us a
headline or uh just to give us a client
tried to dox me very well i doxed him
back
all right nice
sounds much more wholesome seven months
of work and i only denied one regular
from returning he pressed me to book a
ritz-carlton super five-star hotel for
in-calls without being willing to pay
for the room [ __ ] that dude
what there's some more stuff that i'll
skip here last minute cancellations on
that and also he took sneaky photos
during sessions without my permission
and then he tried to make him do a game
show
[Laughter]
so after i blacklisted him he created an
instagram imposter account using my face
oh um or using no sorry i was using a
face swap app to restore my face so uh
some features were obviously mine
um and he was pretty fully done overall
but he followed all my clients and my
instagram followers
uh and potential friends
and wrote posts about my face revealing
picture if you'd like that i'll take
more and like identify moles on certain
parts of my body uh my clients who'd
already seen me thought he stole the
pictures from an old-time actress and
that they were fake um i did not do real
name screening so he thought i had no
way to bite back however he didn't
realize that he's a junior banker at
ex-investment bank and i had very many
connections in that bank and it didn't
take me long to figure out his real name
i'd i'd be considering doing on to right
into that banker report as well so i
pasted his real name and linkedin and
poorly edited his face swap on my own
instagram and twitter
explained the story and his instagram
and linkedin were both taken down and my
clients and friends helped her report as
well wow so basically she found out his
name and then doxed him on her own
account while she was trying to [ __ ] her
up on a damn private true love story
creeping
yeah
that's like it sounds like a subreddit
it's certainly an insight
into that it's really interesting sure
and i appreciate that it's one of the
only places where only people who
actually work in a field are allowed to
post because like if they were a game
dev subreddit i'm sure i'd find that
really fascinating to read but there's
no way there is
it sounds like a reddit
it sounds like a reddit
thread where you just walk away feeling
very disenfranchised about some of it's
sad but some of it's some of it's not
like some of it is really gross um but
yeah some of it's absolutely not like
there are some that are like yeah
there's this guy that i really look
forward forward to seeing because
he generally just wants to talk and
cuddle and sometimes we'll have sex but
if we do it's like nice pleasant
experience like some of them are like
very positive and it's it's just really
eye-opening and um
interesting place to go there it has 99
000 members so a lot of people follow
that's definitely not rich but yeah
here's the thing if your
i'm in amsterdam i'm looking for a sex
wife
go on um and i have a list here
of
all of the the the best
sex shows
because they have live sex shows
yeah where you can go and experience
sex second hand
um
and so i have this list and i want
because i'm not you know i'm not going
to hire an escort and have sex with her
but i will go to a sex show to do an
investigation for you rocky so we're
going to pick one for you yeah so this
is the theater of the porn world
yes
yeah yeah yeah it's theater
um
shakespeare
uh okay so here's the first one yeah
hold on let me make this bigger because
i'm old
um i made a list with the perks of each
one
club bonton
it is a strip club
uh
but it also has optional perks for 300
euros an hour which is double what it's
supposed to be that's why if you you
don't want to go to the red light
district for escorts because it's double
what it normally is
uh and fun fact during the day they sell
a brothel tour hosted by real sex
workers
and i get to choose which one you're
going to do yeah so that one's kind of
straightforward
no he said for me
well we will discuss it all but it's up
it's up to rahul okay because he's the
president of pervert
yeah this one's just an honorable
mention because i'm not actually allowed
to go it's called cocktails
and it's a male strip show for female
only attendance
sadly
that's what i wanted to go to that one
i'm gonna put that can i put a pin in
that one no
you're not allowed i can't go yeah
because magic mike is one of my favorite
movies
i've never seen it so i've never seen it
should we do a watch party we should do
a watch party yeah magic mike and then
magic mike xxl
all right so here's this is a mainstay
casa rosso is one of the most like
well-known
uh live sex show establishments it was
established over 50 years ago that was
the first one right i think i've heard
of that before yeah and
according to the blog post i was reading
the same couple has been performing
there for 16 years
but that was written in 2015 so maybe
they found a new couple
um
hopefully but also if it's if it's the
original couple i would be
almost thinking of sending you well
let's think there was also something
that i was like oh damn i'd love to see
that it was uh it was a tour of the red
light district
uh with two
of the most famous uh sex workers that
were retired they were both it showed
pictures they both looked like 75 years
old yeah and you could get a walking
tour you'd walk around with them and
they'd be like this is where i gave my
first blowie
but i looked it up and it says tickets
aren't available now no no
yeah i don't know
sorry
didn't it
because they're over 50.
oh maybe yeah they're they're having a
problem you got to protect them yeah um
now casa rosso apart from the resident
couple you can
you can also see a woman smoke a cigar
with her vagina
so
that is pretty interesting that's a
pretty good one this is the stuff i was
looking for i was i was waiting for the
more theatrical
little acrobatics but i want to see some
like magic tricks all right so for the
modern day for you zoomers
uh there's one called 5d porn cinema
which isn't actually a live sex show but
it is jacob like when we saw
that wind movie whatever it was called
um [ __ ]
they like shot wind at you
and like sprayed mist up in the air to
make it seem like it was raining
like the simpsons ride on universal yes
but a 90-minute movie
yeah a 90-minute movie where
near the end it went dark it went to
black
and it was like the climactic moment and
then went boom and it cut to them like
in the sky
and both jacob and i like
jumped out of our seats because like the
air cannons shot off in the room and we
like we screamed in the small theater
people we were like
oh my god if some parts were actually
pretty cool
yeah but they were probably the snow was
the worst though because it was just
like a bubble machine
the snow was bad because it
we were watching it on a projector so
the snow would come down and the shadow
of all the snowflakes
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can see a sex
version of this yeah yeah so they're
like squirting things at you or
something i don't know what they're
doing but all i saw was there was a
picture of the audience wearing 3d
glasses
surrounded by what looked like fire
um
i only i want this if there's if there
was a way to ask for permission say
you're a journalist from america and
have a gopro so we can see when things
spray
if i can have that but have a cam just
on you not on the screen if there's a
way for us to arrange that as a tourism
we should you should do this one
as well as an and yeah this one you do
as well
okay we'll pick one that's live yeah one
you just
willing to do this you know we'll do
we'll sort that out
we want to see which senses it appeals
to it's like yeah if it's like shrek
yeah can we have is there a way we can
have a job
like on a on a gopro selfie i mean you
can ask john you could ask but i
wouldn't do that without that yeah i
don't know maybe if i sit in the back
away from people
yeah and just like that you will get
caught that that this is
they'll say i'm a youtuber
or just my face i won't record the show
i'm just gonna record my face when we
say we're on a podcast and you're doing
travel and you can show them the
previous episodes and we can ask and
maybe you can do a yes if it's not a
long film
i'm going to show you
um all right next one now this one i
really don't want to do uh it's called
the banana bar
um and you can eat a banana out of a
woman's snatch
okay um okay yeah and just the thought
of a woman waddling up to me with a
vagina or with a banana in her vagina
and like presenting it to me that's like
the least
that's like a a nightmare i've had i
think is she does she peel it with a
vagina
maybe
it is part of your five a day yeah yeah
you're gonna need some some potassium
while you're over there yeah you did
that's true yeah pus potassium
also dancers will sign a postcard using
their
vaginas um i don't think that they like
stamp on it i think they you know have a
pin
so they can write us a message to jacob
yeah yeah oh
oh they might just sign it but i can ask
them to write yeah like i'd love to
watch a gundam anime with you jacob yeah
if they use
like a dildo with a pen on the end or if
it's just a pen because they feel like
just it's kegels that's tough to control
candles or not you know we're leaning
towards this
banana
the banana thing is recall to me the
postcard is so is it to me all so well
listen
oh but you'd eat some [ __ ] fish from
korea that doug told you to have that
was like you said the consistency you
won't eat a banana out of a vagina
a self-cleaning that's feminist brother
john what if like if she's if she's
clutching it by the peel and it's like
partially peeled
oh
that would actually make it the skin
it's the skin the skin's going to be
inside
it's not going to depend no it's a fully
peeled banana
that's what i assumed it was fully
peeled which is gross
you don't have to leave it
on the bottom she shoots it out of the
last person's mouth
no
she doesn't
i don't like it i don't like it do it
well i'm paying for this apparently
um and uh the last little thing was that
was that in the reviews like we would
not really recommend this sex show to
women
i don't know why we would need bananas
too
yeah clearly
potassium what are you all about
so the next place is called sex palace
peep show
and this one is like those old school i
don't know if you guys remember there
used to be these things called peep
shows where it was like you had your own
little private booth
and you put in a dollar and like the
screen would slide
and you could watch a lady dance or
whatever yeah this is that same thing
and it's a euro a minute
uh but the review said it's a little
awkward because you can it's like in a
circle
you can see you ever see all the other
people in the booths
that's
weird that's really awesome i would only
want you to do that if you were going
with a friend
yeah
i'd want to know
opposite sides yeah i'd want both of you
for both maximum awkwardness if you're
going alone i don't think i care because
it's just you and some random dudes
you'll never see again but if you're
with a friend then i think that would be
more
i would be more inclined to choose that
yeah um i had a weird quick story about
that in vancouver there's a
a sex shop which had
and i'd lived there for years and in a
neon sign it said 99 cent peep show
and
i thought how bad what is a 99 cent peep
show i have to see this
and they never did
and one year uh me and one of my
co-stars got so like blackout drunk we
were walking past him relationship
before i know what this peeps show is
we went in
and none of us had the money but we went
into this you didn't have 99 cents we
only had like cash i don't know we just
we just ended up not doing the peep show
but we went into the booth
and it was like dingy and dark and
whatever the [ __ ] and we realized you
just watched we found out from the guy
working there he was like oh it's just
an old film it's just an old hardcore
film we show it on the screen and we
charge you a dot like a dollar weird
oh [ __ ] that we don't care that's why we
weren't interested
before the internet existed that's how
people
saw
got arrested for winking off inside a
sex theater that was like a block away
from where you live
that was the same thing
but they expect people not to masturbate
inside different yeah
fred willard
so yeah i any so i think when we found
because at first
my thought was when i thought peep so i
thought it was like what john was
talking about where you know the glass
moves and there's a human
yeah yeah and it's nice there's just one
lady who like sits in the back of the
sex shop
never interacting with anyone she just
lives in the booth waiting yeah waiting
for the thing to open
yeah because i think i remember it from
one of the crows sequels that's how one
of them dies and then when the glass
goes up the crow was sitting there and
he went you wanted me oh no that's baby
eric
eric's
number two
city
the prequel to all saints day may i
remember from the i don't know anyway
point being
when we found out it wasn't a human it
was just a dirty movie and a crap one of
that we're like get the [ __ ] out we're
not doing this so we take a quick selfie
in the booth
me and my co-star and then we leave
and we send it to the group
now when we took the picture of me it
was dark and my boy had to put the flash
on okay the following morning when i
came to
i saw the group chat from the rest of
our our our colleagues they were like
that's [ __ ] disgusting what the [ __ ]
never touched me again i was like what
the [ __ ] are they talking about i open
the picture and my hand is to balance is
on stains on the [ __ ]
booth
and i didn't know so i'm like that with
with the thing and my hand you can
clearly see muck so just dry jizz and
[ __ ]
and me and my boy were like yeah
that's a splash make it bring it like
really did you wash your hands i still
haven't
nice
i just imagine you woke up and you saw
it and then you went hold on a second
[Laughter]
um
so is that that was that all the choices
we have that's there's one honorable
mission as well it's called the hospital
bar
it's basically just a strip club uh with
perks uh where they dress up as nurses
or whatever
but on that page which it wasn't the
official page for the hospital bar it
was just like
a blog that posted about stuff in the
red light district there was a comment
that i found very intriguing
um it was from an
anonymous source but it says
irina was my first woman ever i love her
so much
is it possible to get her cell number
i've been to the hospital bar with two
other friends on february 2nd 2016.
please help me
so
maybe i go there and i ask for arena
2016 she's probably not there broth
what she's dead
that's not that long ago that's five
years later
people saying she hates me
no no she aged out but five years to
think that the same dancer that
someone's mentioning is still there it
does seem sort of unlikely yeah um yeah
she's moving
i'll tell you what i'm leaning towards
i'm willing to sponsor
and hear about the 5d sex show i think
that sounds wonderful i would love if we
can get in contact and have you gopro i
mean we could we could we can make it a
promotional thing we can shout them out
we'll shout them out yeah
and we just want your reactions we'll
watch them live together yeah we just
want to see the ins and outs of it like
when you can't see anything and the
liquid looks from your face
there's one that i find did you mention
the the
um moulin rouge one
that one got terrible reviews
literally multiple reviews i saw said
it's like watching robots dance
i was like okay supposedly that one is
like a kind of a tourist trap i guess
i think i'm gonna go with the sex show
and i would like a postcard written from
a buy a vagina to jacob
john this is such a bad covert situation
though it says the buyers may take turns
chomping out bites to completion uh yeah
so you're all eating the same one banana
yeah you're all gonna get sick but not
yeah so bring a friend
yeah i'm not gonna do it though go first
take the biggest bite also there's like
a 80 vex vaccination rate in amsterdam
that's the other great thing about
amsterdam i don't have to wear a mask
just on public transit
because everybody's backed up
follow the rules
you can sign branded postcards and make
sex toys if the banana comes if if the
banana's inside the puss the skin's
still on it
no and you get to go first and get a
good bite out of it before the other um
eat the banana but banana optional i
really want a postcard written to baby
boy jacob from a puss
love jacob okay okay
do we care what it says or do whatever i
would like a gundam reference if she's
got the dexterity
can you get her to write do you want to
watch a gundam anime or i will watch a
gundam anime with you jacob
i love gundam
jacob i feel like we can't have it be a
full sentence yeah we don't we don't
know what the parameters don't know what
her skills are her penmanship that's
true why else would it be a postcard
it's not just a signature it's a whole
postcard yeah that's an autograph
it says if she could write a message
gundam and may jacob gundam destiny
i'll take anything something in there
gundam anime jacob gundam destiny
question
no star wars that's played out
when i was looking at just normal
activities i did find a nude painting
workshop oh cool which would be way
cheaper i think than going down you're
going to pay
a nude
yeah well that's not supposed to be
sexual john that's a whole different
thing basically it's like going to a
live sex show but it's way cheaper it'd
be amazing if we could auction that and
then give the proceeds to charity well
the twist is that john's gonna be the
model that's what the workshop is they
rip all your clothes off put you on the
turntable prairie prison
if we had new jacob on your stomach
like like like this as a i would pay
hundreds to to be in that club hundreds
what the jacob the new drawing i made
did we talk about that last time
i don't know if we showed it to anyone
i think we talked about the shirts
last time a picture of it i've got a
picture of christmas
and everybody drew jacob naked on repeat
well mostly john john drew me naked
multiple times yeah specific style very
well
it was jacob talking about like this one
there it is scale it up
so what are your list is it's a t-shirt
that's jacob bent over naked and the
text says put your mouth on it
um i also have a confession to make very
good um
i bought that shirt
and i think it shrunk
i'm terrible with with washing
i thought it would be funny i
i donated it to the salvation army
god do i hope that out somewhere in la
right now
someone is wearing a baby boy jacob
shirt that says put your mouth on it oh
my god i thought that was the best way
to deal with it i was like i want it
just out there somewhere a rogue jacob
shirt yeah i still got the one i got
it's the banana with the condom on it
that says jacob's filipinas very good i
still have the one of the toilet it's
just someone drew a toilet and it just
has the words i zombie
yeah
it's the best match
i just imagine a young curly-haired
filipino boy
like
walking into goodwill going oh the mom's
like you can get one one thing he's
flipping through he goes oh my god
it's me
go buy this one grandma
um we've been recording for two hours
yeah
look at that all right yeah yeah this is
a once a month podcast that's gotta be a
little bit longer
i also want to apologize if i've seen
distracted for the last 30 minutes i'm
trying to get milk
because yeah cause you threw it all out
explain is that
the thought you're trying to record
the way you went out it sounds like
you're milking yourself the angle you're
just trying and you're like if you're if
i've been distracted buzzing sounds
trying to get milk no
um yeah my power went out before we were
recorded and even though it was only out
for two hours i for some reason was like
gotta throw my milk out power's out the
fridge when i could have just left the
fridge closed and then everything would
have been fine because it wasn't for
long enough
so i threw my milk out that's a mistake
i [ __ ] up uh i feel i feel pretty
upset about it so i've been trying to
order new milk that's my friend um we
also didn't talk at all about mexico but
i don't have a ton to say went to cabo
on the way back from nicaragua
um
and
you stay in these like resort
all-inclusive hotels and i was like this
is pretty expensive when i booked it and
then when i got there they were like
yeah so all food and drinks are included
i was like what
alcohol and they're like yeah all food
and drinks i was like oh this wasn't
that expensive yeah exactly
exclusive it's like gold nuts also it
was no kids allowed so there were no
children oh hell yeah
which i'm a huge fan of because kids in
pools ruin vacations it's it's a known
truth
raffle what the [ __ ]
oh what did you say he said oh [ __ ] that
because he wants to go holiday with kids
that's terrible
oh by the way i wouldn't talk about my
family
with my family and my godson you would
not be visiting the anne frank i will
not be visiting the anne frank house
you're not a fan of why is that
anyways thanks everybody
uh mexico is fun cabo is a place that's
kind of like vegas where everyone had an
american accent and it is definitely not
indicative of what mexico actually is
obviously uh it feels very resort-y very
like fabricated um but it was also
beautiful like very hot but but really
beautiful the sunsets there were [ __ ]
amazing oh yeah
and i keep accidentally speaking to
people in spanish now because i was in
spanish-speaking countries for like
three to four weeks so give us some of
that
uh see
wow
we did go on a yacht yep we've all had
lots of adventures but i don't think we
should i feel like we should stop at
some point two hours is an intimidation
yeah but there's so much happen on the
yacht
on a big speaker and jacob twerked on
the boat yeah
lawrence just kind of sat out the front
for a while listening to his own music
in a phone and everybody got panicked
and laurence was wearing a romper that
is based on sean connery's the towel one
yeah oh yeah dr no i have a great video
of him just like he's just on the bow of
the moving boat like jam into a song
that nobody could hear yeah i respect
that
though else happen
we realized that bruce looks like
someone who owns a boat
yeah and also that he can sing all of
the lyrics to that yakuza song
yeah he knows all the lyrics so do i so
we blasted that leg's got sunburned and
i got you see the fingerprints yeah
where tara like touched me with their
100 spf
yeah my nose is real bad for sure
it was a good time
what else happened
yeah but everything else was lovely we
saw hella dolphins oh the photos at the
at the brunch place the the weird
pictures that we took oh my god it was
so strange brunch was amazing we're all
sitting there
john wasn't bad
all the rest of us were there um and
we're getting brunch before we go on the
boat because when you drink on the boat
and also if you're in the sun it's just
a bad time you gotta eat first um and
this woman comes over and is like
i don't know what she said but it was
like can i take a picture
so she walks over with his camera
and then just like sort of forces a
picture to be taken and we were like
okay
and then she groups people up who like
don't even really
there's a group together well tara and
lawrence
yeah yeah
me and sean charlotte
i'm completely hidden
by charlotte yeah you can just sort of
see my arm but everyone else is in
perfect frame
it's very strange and the way she spoke
to me
the way she directed me because it kind
of like triggered me a little bit
um i when she was well left i i was like
look i don't i don't [ __ ] let
directors
with experience talk to me like that on
set the way she was like no you stan put
together you two to me and charlotte
i was so upset
she was like who are you
how dare you speak to me like she like
went to other we were like is this a
promotional photo for like their
instagram or something and she went to
other tables and she was telling people
to take their masks off she was like
yeah together
um and it turns out it was all to be
sold to us they came back and had them
printed out and tried to sell them to us
none of us bought one but they're all
bad photos yeah probably like the
weirdest thing was like usually you buy
them and then they print them out but
yeah spend the ink and the like yeah
they do the photo paper and stuff they
print all of all the pictures out first
and say do you want to buy all these and
they were all bad and she gave me
one to consider to buy the group one
where i'm clearly not in it because
charlotte's blocked me
she handed it to me and i was like you
know what do you think
it was a lot it was it was so strange it
was worse but john you're you're coming
back for a bit
next yeah i come back mid-september
that's super exciting
yeah
so we're gonna fight with my friend what
are we gonna play hell yeah we're gonna
play
we're gonna build gundams together
propositions and check each other are
you are you back are you back on the
gundam train hey
how about you
hold on
oh wait very good what's the back side
of that arm look like
ow
that's very cute
it's
i don't know is that that's a wing
gundam it's wing gundam zero ew verka
wait let me double check from my uh my
new book i got from oh my god
mechanical designing gundams and very
nice well look i'm working on the one
from the when we won fall guys i've been
working on it oh sassaby yeah big and
red oh look nice i like zasabi oh uh uh
here's the thigh piece it's the only
thing that was yeah this is the perfect
time to end this guys i finally ordered
my milk um but yeah i i i
the next episode will be up on
because we're the first monday of every
month
it will be
october 4th and i would love to i i
don't want to promise this to the
audience of this show because i don't
know how it works logistically but we
will try to record it in person
um while john that was gonna be a
surprise but yeah okay well i just don't
know if we can even so we'll see if we
can make that happen
um
four of us in one room with full
microphones easily can i plug something
yeah go ahead pizzabuzzy.com newbursh
just dropped check it out
can i plug something yeah
midnight massage
september 24th on netflix yes
jacob
i think uh oh we did a fun house video
with john just came out
cool we did
yeah
oh survival yeah we were running around
acting like monkeys hell yeah that was a
good time that's all i got i can't think
of anything else excellent
thank you we'll be selling the jacob's
butthole
in
west l.a no where am i east l.a yeah
there's a jacob
butt shirt floating
all right we'll see you all next month
thank you everybody see y'all
it's so good it's very good